hello and welcome the Japanese prime
minister says that he intends to have
Frank talks with the South Korean
president in Seoul fumia kashida's trip
to South Korea's prime minister is the
first official visit by a Japanese
leader in 12 years this comes just two
months after the leaders met in Tokyo
they are trying to repair relations
strained by historical issues mostly
related to Japan's occupation of Korea
from 1910 to 1945.
the governments are cooperating on
defense in the face of North Korea's
nuclear threat and China's growing
influence
let's go to Rob McBride who's live for
us in Seoul Rob tell us about the
prospects for the visit what does it
mean for improving relations
yeah it certainly does indicate the
warming relations after years when we
saw this souring of relations between
Tokyo and uh and Seoul you have to go
back to 2011 when we had the last such
Summit visit by a Japanese prime
minister here and it does follow a visit
by junsa Goldie a South Korean president
as a guest of kashida to Tokyo in
mid-march when the two agreed to restart
shuttle diplomacy they will be talking
uh uh at their Summit meeting most
significantly about Security in the face
of North Korean threats both leaders
take a very tough line when it comes to
this provocative missile testing by
North Korea but they'll also be talking
about greater collaboration on high-tech
Industries especially on strategically
significant and sensitive components
like semiconductors and all of this has
been helped by the re-establishing of
preferential trading status which had
been withdrawn in a tit-for-tat dispute
arising from the treatment a
compensation for wartime forced labor
South Koreans forced to work in World
War II Japanese factories that Yun
sukyol now believes he has resolved
allowing for much closer ties with Japan
okay thank you for that Rob McBride
speaking to us there from Seoul we can
speak now to Benoit Hardy chatran he's
an Adjunct professor political science
at International Affairs at Temple
University Japan joins us now from Tokyo
really good of you to join us sir there
is of course as we've been hearing a lot
of difficult history between these two
countries how determined are they really
the two sides in improving relations
oh I think they are truly determined
it's been um for a few years actually
that both sides have been talking about
uh improving the relations and on top of
that there's been the United States uh
who is the most important Ally of both
countries that has been pushing uh the
two countries to mend these ties because
it makes it a lot easier for the United
States to
um you know Advance its interests in the
region if it's two Regional allies are
able to have or establish their
relations on a more stable footing so I
would say one of the biggest changes was
the election of Yun sokyo the South
Korean president unlike the previous
South Korean president he has been very
keen to improve relations with uh with
Japan we've seen that with a visit of
Yoon to Tokyo about two months ago in
March and uh now with this visit by the
Prime Minister
um kishida to South Korea the two sides
really seem set to embark on a new
journey toward it's more stability after
10 years of frankly quite difficult
relationships you mentioned the U.S
clearly this is in the interests of the
of Washington's indo-pacific strategy I
mean how much pressure do you think has
there been from the US on these two
countries to make sure uh relations
improve
oh quite a bit and I think that pressure
the United States has been quite open
about you know trying to get its allies
to get along and to improve the
relations over the last 10 years going
back to uh President Barack Obama uh
same thing for president Donald Trump
um the high officials in Washington DC
were constantly talking about uh their
desire for better relations between
Seoul and Tokyo but the reality is as
much as Washington is a key Ally for
these both countries it has limited
leeway when it comes to what it can do
in the bilateral relations between Seoul
and Tokyo so regardless of their efforts
none of this was going to be possible
without the real uh desire on both sides
on both sides now in the case of Tokyo
this desire has been there for a few
years but like I said with this change
of administration in South Korea finally
we're kind of seeing a Confluence of
factors that uh that allow us to that
allow this relationship to to move to a
new level it's interesting that
domestically the South Korean public
don't appear to be happy about their PM
strategy it hasn't his popularity has
taken a huge hit at home
is is it similar in Japan
um no it's I would say it's quite
different in Japan although in Japan of
course there is a degree of resentment I
would say over the South Korean uh
political attitude towards Japan and
there is also a sense of kind of fatigue
over these repeated requests by South
Korea for greater apologies on the side
of Japan overall there's been more a
desire on the part of the Japanese
public and the Japanese government to
move on from this difficult relationship
but indeed as you mentioned in South
Korea the domestic pressure has been
quite an issue for years in fact the
anti-japanese sentiment in South Korea
historically has been very high many
South Korean politicians including South
Korean presidents in fact have also
played on that
anti-japanese sentiment so this makes it
harder for many Korean leaders to
reinforce to re-establish and improve
relations with South Korea because very
often they will face a blowback from the
south South Korean public if they try to
go too fast in improving relations with
Tokyo
now China will be watching all this very
closely I mean how can how kind will
they be
well for China obviously having allies
of the United States improving their
relations it's not something that is in
its interest for this reason China with
successive South Korean administrations
it has tried to kind of woo South Korea
away from the American orbit and closer
within its fear of influence this has
been easier with certain South Korean
presidents now with the current South
Korean president Ewan he has been
somewhat critical of China he has also
expressed a desire for closer relations
with the United States so this is not
welcome for China obviously because this
kind of Greater coordination between
Japan the United States and South Korea
uh just makes it
um easier for the United States to
advance its interests and harder for
China to do it for itself in the region
so no this is not going to be a very
welcome development depending on the
outcome but this will not be uh very
welcome development for Beijing okay
good of you to join us Benoit Hardy
shatran Adjunct professor political
science and international Affairs at
Temple University in Japan thank you
[Applause]